We all encounter insecurity at
one point or another in our lives,
probably...
multiple occurrences in our lives,
and yet we all deal with it just a little bit differently.
There's the one-uppers,
Oh, you speak Spanish?
Ah, me too!
Although I also speak Japanese.
Trilingual.
The people who take offense,
I love watching romantic comedies.
You wanna laugh at my love life?!
The people pleasers,
Here's all my money.
The ones that put you down,
Wow!
That was not funny.
You are not funny.
You should stop making Youtube videos.
The ones that put themselves down,
Wow.
That was not funny.
I am not funny.
I should stop making internet videos.
(accent) The fishermen...
I'm so stupid.
Right?
I'm so ugly.
I'm so wrong...
Right?
And the deflectors.
I thought it was so well written.
HUMOR!
Get your fucking compliments away from me, bruh.
I like to define insecurity
as the Eye of Sauron.
Bearing down upon you,
so that every move you make
or thought you think
or word you say
is just UNDER HIS SCRUTINY.
And I found that the best way to deal with Sauron
is to try and forget myself.
So if I'm talking to another person,
I will put all my concentration on them.
So that there's literally no attention left
to reflect back on me.
I also used to pretend that I was invisible,
no one can see me, therefore
no one can judge me...hmmhmmhmm.
The best thing to do
is to just really remember
when you think about how tiny we are
in the grand scheme of things.
Like, just imagine yourself standing next to the ocean
and like, how fucking big that ocean is.
Or how fucking big our planet is,
or the universe in its unfathomable EXPANSIONS,
like that kind of stuff makes
my insecurities about
my vagina, or if I possibly have cameltoe,
or if my butt looks weird
just seem so stupid.
Anyway, I hope this video helped.
And if not, then it doesn't matter
because stars are fucking ginormous
balls of gasses that twinkle in the sky
and they're beautiful.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
I really do worry more about cameltoe
more than I have--
more than I feel like you should have
to worry about cameltoe.
Like how often...
does cameltoe plague you?
I don't know, but I don't want it.
I don't want..
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara